Chandler is one of the kindest people
I've ever known which is really
fantastic bindi and the rest of the
Irwin family were in full force at the
Steve Irwin gala dinner on Saturday in
Los Angeles but bindi couldn't stop
gushing about her boyfriend Chandler
Powell two et must be nice to have a
partner in crime who cares so much about
the same kind of issues you do I'm sure
absolutely I think that he is very
patient which sometimes I like a lot of
patience if I want to do something I
have to do it instantly
he's a very patient person and just
loves wildlife and conservation it's
great to be able to find somebody who
shares the same values the cute couple
posed for pics on the red carpet but the
Dancing with the Stars alum says her
beau is still adjusting to making public
appearances he's awake fauna and he's
usually outside running around say this
is kind of new but luckily he had some
experience with his wakeboarding work
but we're getting there slowly but
surely